[Musique]
lors de l'été en pleine crise économique
que vous avez voulu présenter en
catimini la seconde lecture du texte
bioéthique
mes chers collègues là je vais citer les
défenseurs de la loi qui ont dit de
cette loi c'est un changement de
civilisation ce n'est pas nous qui le
disons c'est vous on aurait aimé vous
entendre monsieur le premier ministre
sur la réécriture du droit de la
filiation sur les changes de vos sites
au sein de couples de femmes qui est une
forme de gpa à laquelle vous prétendez
vous opposez sur le tri des embryons
monsieur le premier ministre sur le tri
des embryons pour dépister le handicap
en contradiction avec l'inclusion que
nous prenons tous sur le mélange
monstrueux des cellules animales et
humaines transgressant la barrière des
espèces
voilà la réalité de cette loi qui
franchit les limites éthiques dont vous
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
choisi de ne rien dire
avez vous l'intention de créer ses 15000
places de prison comme s'y était engagé
le président de la république même si le
nombre a baissé depuis
où avez vous l'intention de désemplir
les prisons puisque le garde des sceaux
a annoncé lors de sa visite à la prison
de fresnes devant son taux d'occupation
historiquement bas que c'est le chemin
qu'il fallait poursuivre désormais
monsieur le ministre au fond ce que nous
attendons d'un au territoire c'est la
proximité de la justice et pas la
justice de proximité
depuis quelques semaines les actes de
violences de nature délictuelle ou
criminelle se multiplient à l'égard de
policiers à l'égard de gendarmes à
l'égard de pompiers ou tout simplement à
l'égard de nos concitoyens quelle est la
politique pénale que vous ce que le
gouvernement souhaite porter à l'égard
de ces deux actes de violence qui se
multiplient parce que lui finalement les
délinquants n'ont plus peur de rien et
nous avons souvent entendu à cette
tribune que les moyens à l'aide de
données que l'on allait agir et nous
avons souvent rien vu venir
donc ce que nous vous demandons monsieur
nice monsieur le premier je me permets
de m'adresser à vous c'est véritablement
de faire
très vite on habite à monsieur le
premier ministre vous vous dites
gaulliste social alors chiche pour
relancer l'activité du bâtiment et
générer des emplois locaux allez vous
mener une véritable politique
d'aménagement du territoire
chiche allez vous mener une véritable
politique familiale d'accession à la
propriété
face au péril qui menace le patrimoine
religieux national il convient de
s'interroger sur les moyens financiers
pour assurer la sécurisation des
cathédrales la protection du patrimoine
sa restauration doit être une priorité
pour tous le patrimoine religieux
appartient je viens de le rappeler 87
cathédrale à l'état l'état est
propriétaire l'état est responsable
cette dernière question est l'occasion
de soulever une erreur constitutionnel
que je considère comme majeure celle de
la suppression du mandat de député maire
alors même que ses deux mandats avait
avait tout pour que la légitimité du
peuple français
il sait que reconnu qu'une telle que
reconnue dans l'élaboration de la loi
comment comprendre que l'on puisse
cumuler un mandat de ministre avec un
mandat de maire et qu'un parlementaire
ne le pourrait pas le 14 juillet dernier
le président de la république a confirmé
sa volonté de limiter le transport
aérien intérieur sans définir avec
précision les contours de cette
limitation
certains territoires de la république
n'ont d'autre alternative que le
transport aérien pour se connecter au
reste du pays
c'est le cas de mon département des
pyrénées orientales
je vous suggère de fusionner les
compétences de la région et de la
nouvelle collectivité européenne
d'alsace pour réduire le mille feuille
institutionnel
c'est une mesure qui va dans le bon sens
faire avec un souci d'efficacité et un
souci aussi d'économie dans les coûts de
fonctionnement de nos collectivités
une nouvelle fois la france prend du
retard une nouvelle fois elle est
incapable de mettre en place autrement
que sur le papier ce que presque tous
nos voisins font des contrôles aux
frontières systématique pas seulement
incitatif et au bon vouloir du passager
quelle mère qu'elle membres des forces
de l'ordre quel enseignant n'a pas
entendu parler des cartouches
it de gaz hilarant et constater les
innombrables cartouches usagées qui
jonchent le sol
l'espace public lusage de cartouches de
protoxyde d'azoté aux effets
euphorisants nouvelle mode pour de trop
nombreux jeunes et pas seulement
constitué un danger pour la santé
publique
après des mois de mouvements sociaux
dans la plupart de nos départements
les sapeurs pompiers professionnels
avaient reçu l'engagement du précédent
ministre de l'intérieur sur une
augmentation de leur prime de feu pour
la portée du plafond actuel de 19 % à 25
% depuis janvier et indépendamment du
contexte sanitaire de notre pays le
projet de décret a été soumis à l'avis
de diverses instances
mais le conseil d'évaluation des normes
s'est opposé à ce décret en soulignant
l'absence d'accompagnement de l'état aux
collectivités soit par l'octroi de
nouveaux financements soit par
l'allégement de charges existantes
alors que l'ampleur de la revalorisation
a été déterminé par le gouvernement
[Musique]